is there sort of practical advice you
can give to people on how to meditate or
how to be
mindful in this full way yes I would
tell them to do at least three things
and I was I I I lucked into this uh when
I started meditation I went down the
street and there was a place that taught
the passion of meditation meta
contemplation and Tai Chi Chuan for flow
induction and you should get you should
have a meditative practice
you should find a contemplative practice
and you should find a moving mindfulness
practice especially one that is
conducive to the Flow State and practice
them in an integrated fashion
can you elaborate with those practices
might look like so right generally
speaking meditative practice like
vipassana
um and so what what what's the primary
thing I look through rather than look at
it's my Sensations so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to focus on my
Sensations rather than focusing on the
world through my Sensations so I'm going
to follow for example the sensations in
this area of my of my abdomen where my
breathing is so I can feel as my abdomen
is expanding I can feel those Sensations
and then I can feel the sensation since
it's Contracting now what will happen is
my mind will leap back to trying to look
through and look at the world again
right I'll start thinking about I need
to do my laundry or what was that noise
and so what do I do I don't get involved
with the content
I step back and label the process with
an ing word listening imagining planning
and then I return my attention to the
breath and I have to return my attention
in in the correct way the part of your
mind that jumps around in the Buddhist
tradition this is called your monkey
mind it's like a monkey leaping for
branches and chattering
right if I was trying to train that that
monkey mind to stay or as Jack cornfield
say train a puppy dog
and you know stay puppy dog and if it
goes and I get really angry and I bring
it back and I'm yelling at it I'm going
to train it to fight and fear me yeah
but if I just indulge it if I just feed
its whims oh look the puppy dog went
there oh now it's there puppy dog never
learns to stay what do I need to do I
have to neither fight it nor feed it I
have to have this centered attitude I
have to befriend it so you you step back
and look at your Sensations
you step back and look at your
distracting processes you return your
attention to the breath and you do it
with the right attitude that's the core
of a good meditative practice okay then
what's a good contemplative practice a
good contemplative practice is to try
and
matter it's actually apropos because we
talked about that participatory knowing
the way you're situated in the world so
what this is a long thing because
there's different interpretations of
meta and uh and I go for what's called
an existential interpretation over a an
emotional one but so what I'm doing in
Mata right is I'm trying to become a I'm
trying to awaken in two ways
I'm trying to awaken to the fact that I
am constantly assuming an identity and
assigning an identity so I'm looking at
that
I'm trying to awaken to that and then
I'm trying to awake from the modal
confusion that I can get into around
that and so I'm looking out onto the
world and I'm trying to see
you in a fundamentally different way
than I have before
you know like you go to the gym and you
do bicep curls yeah yes yes is is it
possible to reduce it to those things
that I mean you don't need to speak to
the specifics but is there actual
practice you can do or is it really
personal no I teach people how to do The
Meta practice I also teach them how to
do a neoplatonic contemplative practice
how to do a stoic one another one you
can do is the view from above this is
classic stoicism I get you to imagine
that you're in this room and then
imagine that you're floating above the
room then above Austin then above Texas
then above the United States then the
Earth and you like and you have to
really imagine it don't just think it
but really and then what you notice is
as you're pulling out to a wider and
wider like contemplation of reality your
sense of self and what you find relevant
and important also changes no for all of
these there is a specific step-by-step
methodology so you can so like in that
one you could just literally imagine
yourself floating
farther farther out but you have to go
through the steps yeah because the the
stepping matters because if you just
jump it doesn't work do you have any
other stuff online by the way I do
because during covid I decided
um at the advice of a good friend to do
a daily uh course I taught meditating
with John verakee I did all the way
through meditation contemplation even
some of the movement practices that's
all there it's all available that was
largely inspired by Buddhism and Taoism
and and then I went into the Western
tradition and went through things like
stoicism and neoplatonism cultivating
wisdom with genre that's all there all
free on your website yeah it's on my
YouTube channel yeah on your YouTube
channel okay and that's exciting
um I mean your meaning meaning crisis
lectures is just incredible everything
around it including the notes and the
notes that people took it's just there's
a it created this tree of of
conversations that's really really well
done